yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I'm
just on time but and to tweak something
in the xsplit so I hope everything works
all right okay I hope you all had a good
weekend I'm going to kick off as usual
with a couple of Units games that's cool
okay yeah it wasn't a good idea okay
so let's kick off now someone says
hoping for one a three understands
opening nope I have to disappoint you
I don't play bad openings on purpose so
poco a poco I can't go 1.e4 I mean I
have no idea about it but I can play
some funky four lines if I'm pressed to
do so so here 97 please come on 97 okay
he didn't want to do that maybe he plays
it now no what a shame that would have
been funny now come on 97 okay you can
try I mean you can try it's no harm in
trying
so at the end I really have to settle
for some normal development but it's not
a bad position for white probably equal
but I had some fun hoping for if I did
blunder so let's just develop stuff and
see where we go from there okay have you
been following the London chest classics
today I have not yet been able to so
look I see that Nakamura beat Ireland
but I didn't see how would that happened
naca really has a great scoop against
Arnold I think he won a couple of games
at recent years also in London a couple
of years ago we had a nice win so I'm
feeling Kettering my bishop cm looks a
little bit better for white disposition
I think
a little bit hmm
yeah looks like he's trying to yeah what
is he trying to do taking money for
maybe seems that is happy to have to
trade yeah keep it sing I think we I see
as a broadcast of the event so I don't
want to really do yeah do a broadcast
myself of the of the remaining games and
the Carlton's game is going to be a draw
anyway it's it's it's it's an absolute
draw I mean you don't even have to be a
great technical player like like Micky
Adams --is to make that draw I think I
probably would manage that myself and
I'm not good at acted technical play um
okay so this is not much that Queen is
very very annoying I tried to trade it
hmm it's not it's not going for it
see going for some 95-year I don't quite
understand
maybe yeah hello - AOC train blade and
cool pawn also - Bonjour Schweitzer some
regular guests of that broadcast um yeah
let's just it straight this
okay so we have this endgame yeah I hope
that we have a mod here but it's
possible that our moderator is busy he's
busy with the broadcast of London I
couldn't I didn't get the the moderates
myself I was simply busy doing other
things so I'm going to centralize my
King and see okay
I'm a little bit ahead in time that's
good not sure why you went to f6 it
looks like a weakening threatening G for
now hmm slightly inconvenient now for
him
I'm yeah I'm not so much into the
fallout scenarios that that that game
fallout 4 today I spoke with a student
of mine and he suggested I should do a
let's play
I think I'm what I'm going to do is if
if they do this if they do a successor
to to Skyrim iam
I will definitely play that and I will
do Let's Plays on that one okay
he's giving me the a file Wow what is he
doing here now I've got a seep on
now I've got a c-pawn that's comparable
to John McClane and the die hard movies
right now I've got a machine gun I've
got a C pawn it's not as bad as the
machine gun that still the C point is
not not so not so nice
okay so hmm I'm not sure that I want to
trade this I think I rather not
I can take G form okay we can take you
for but I still want to keep that pawn
okay hmm rook d3 now 437 let's do this
maybe I should take more time you
actually playing this attempt too
quickly he might have a 5 now right no
he gives the exchange okay
hmm but c7s the queen right weird who
was the director of die hard - Renny
Harlin I know stuff like that
I'm good with movie stuff so especially
if the movies are not super current yeah
so I won the first game rare occurence
so let's go with the new 5 minute game
yeah I'm good with stuff like that who
directed this in that movie there was a
question would you be able to steal a
game from Magnus at any time control no
I don't think so but I mean I think that
there was this funny thing that that
Lorenz trend tried young play with play
with them against Magnus with the robots
and I think I could score better than
Lawrence did think I'm not quite sure
how he managed to lose four games the
rook down against Magnus a rope down is
really a lot I mean it's not like two
pawns or something like that the rook is
a lot
I don't follow Game of Thrones so I have
to pass on any quizzes there
yeah I beat Nakamura like three four or
five times but I also lost like 50 or so
so you can always score at the odd game
but the difference is just far far too
big okay should I play something boring
come on I play something boring just
once
yeah
play the exchange line here I have a
really good score with that yeah I think
the Lawrence lost lost most of the games
on time but still I think you shouldn't
ruk ruk odds rakaats is is a lot yeah he
I'm threatening c5 and I'm still within
my book knowledge so let's say what
Victor Kiyoshi is coming up with hello
Walt so two fire-breathing dragon are
you from Skyrim are you one of the
Skyrim dragons probably not I have to
admit that when we when we talked about
those games last week err it made me a
reinstall Skyrim and start a new game
I'm not playing like hours a day but a
little bit and it's fun again visiting
all those places we have been to tons of
times
Bishop to d8 it's funny probably not
such a bad move ok mmm
it's baby before right before yeah then
you wrench played 30 seconds against one
minute I actually took to be honest I
really it's hard to tell but I think 30
seconds against one minute against
months I wouldn't do so bad because I
can actually play really quickly and
over the board
it's I'm very quick with moving the
pieces when I'm trying the same so um
I'm I'm reasonably confident that 30
seconds against one minute I do would do
pretty well
yeah this is not very exciting but at
the same time it's also not very
inspiring for black let's see maybe
Bishop the president was a bit lame to
be honest but he didn't do anything okay
I thought that he might play Twix Bishop
d7
and somehow tried to do something
against me coming to d5 to receive the I
am title after age 40 if he irate ignite
if he rated 1900 now that's very
difficult it I have to be honest there
that's very difficult so let's see okay
I think I wanted to go Knight to d3 but
getting it to d6 looks even better
there should be six okay hmm well if he
takes it those pawns should be dangerous
yeah everybody can become I am with
intense training I don't think that I
don't that I don't think that's true
even though it might be some Russian
saying but it's not true
some people simply don't have the talent
and it's it's AB it's a matter of when
you start also a little bit if you
really start the intense training at 14
then it's it's very difficult to do okay
so it's moving as pawns up I think I'm
trying to open the GE file my pawns are
very dangerous
so what is he doing
yeah I think I'm going up I don't I
don't believe that this is so dangerous
and now I thought Knight to d6 must be
good
I just hope that his pawns are not so
dangerous I think they they cannot do
much hope I'm right there
so King f5 I guess and then c6
yeah something I mean I'm usually more
of a bishop person but the 90 26 it's
pretty strong there's a question by mu
quit seeing in my in my book I mentioned
that I'm a chess book addict is there
any advice for chess book addicts how to
get rid of that addiction well it
depends a little bit I think it's one of
the addictions that are not that yeah
that that terrible I mean it's not it's
not like you are addicted to some sort
of yeah some sort of morphine or
something like that so I think we all
need our our yeah our guilty guilty
pleasures and if we're it's just chess
books I think we should be okay with
that okay I'm trying to do this yeah and
hope that this is a good a good choice
taking on g6 and 93 was my idea Oh is
there something better and then I hoped
I hope that c6 witness couldn't really
see a defense King e7 such a willing
yeah some of the older books they they
might be they might have some some value
we have you're right so I think I'm
taking this so that the deep horn will
not Queen with check
so what is this is it an idea to move
the night so that like here he
threatening to take and play d2 if I
play c7 takes when I can just promote
right I can promote now on if I take D
to Queens hmm I don't see you in there
but I can promote him okay
nice he's fighting he's fighting it
slightly pointless okay so this is made
right yeah so win the win
yeah reading chess books reading chess
books to help your your boardvision
yeah it's a it helps if you have if you
have if you read a book without setting
the the board up that's kind of useful
yeah I think my system is a is a good
book form for an advanced player to
understand the development of chess
concepts better but it's not a good a
good book form for for a beginning
player let's save as many things I kind
of weird to be honest rope nalddo rope
nailed oh yes your fan of Cristiano
Ronaldo that wouldn't tell something
good about your taste anyway so we've
got the Zurich variation in Hana of our
viewer here is our Schweitzer let's see
I can actually take with the Queen there
if he likes doesn't okay I can go to e7
or back to b8 but I like this and I'm
happy to get the bishop here if he know
that's an interesting position actually
and let me think about it I think I'm
going to be six
the best thing about Cristiano Ronaldo
is that he always plays badly against
Germany always have a good laugh when he
plays against us so let's see how to
regroup this getting this night over to
have six looks kind of weird I know but
let's see
with plated tea plated in a good way
here I didn't expect this to happen here
Bishop III adds a good move hmm oh
that's indeed true
no that's so good
what did I do here - to get to this
crappy position hmm
I just played a dinner far too relaxed
fashion
I'm not sure I should've gone 85 hmm
has Cristiano Ronaldo ever scored with
the free kick I always only see this
weird kind of when he positions himself
with the ball and then never does
anything good anyway so this is um yeah
the kind of position that you sometimes
get my kink position looks a bit on
evade but maybe maybe makes a mistake
trade Queen so he trades Queens no
that's good now I like my position again
I mean not that I'm better but at least
I have some ideas
hmm do I get some play on the fo maybe
King is 7 kg 5 of course and I have H 5
H 4 yeah this is this is slightly more
comfortable now for me just slightly
it's probably still dry
it's still dry
see no way forward it's probably draw
hmm I wonder okay maybe I can if I get
to know he's just closing down the whole
thing very intent on a draw
yeah but anyway I'm going to going to
try him hmm
I just wanna know what's the best way to
do it probably go away there
yeah c6c can take and play route d5 okay
I got offered row there okay he took it
so yeah that wasn't good but the draw is
the draw as a draw what can you do
there's a question how many daily blitz
games and my stock right now
mmm not so much just a couple I think
can you play the Scandinavian hmm yeah I
can do it but don't expect wonders yeah
I could have played b5 but I couldn't
really see where it leads me going to
request the game but didn't get one yet
so I think
oh here we go Oh J is something dodgy is
72 so maybe for a Queen's Gambit or
something else can I do something else
okay I know that doesn't look very
aggressive but there are a couple of
ideas this is one of them he just fell
right into that little trap here black
already is in slide trouble okay this is
a good defense that's a good move but
White has a slight advantage here maybe
couldn't be three okay
now that looks kind of nice right why
why is he playing instant moves
who said so easy this position yeah I
don't know I always feel like a bad
chess player when I play against many
guys they just play move after move yeah
just like machines and I cannot do that
I always have to think a little bit so
okay um it's t5 good cheer or what does
this come on that give me give me the
bishop pair please the complete bishop
pair no okay so I go before now that
looks good for watch 95 blunders a pawn
oh I forgot about this move that's
embarrassing okay it's not a big deal
so here hmm
yeah do I take the five that doesn't
look good
let's open up
let's open this up
yeah someone says that Maurice Ashley
said Topalov was winning 20 minutes ago
yeah that can we can happen because
Ashley just usually just reads out the
computer evaluation and adds no human
element to his to his own thoughts
sometimes it's just a bit weird because
the position sometimes are not clear at
all and he just says someone is flat out
winning and I don't know sometimes why
this should be the case yeah there are
still humans playing the games okay so
here I can cross try to tableau Ruby
wonders rupee age that doesn't help
Jack probably equal probably equal or I
see invading on the beef file or
something I don't don't know I don't
think I should be in trouble here
hmmm interesting hey trust to fix that
party for hmm I can't go Bishop d2 maybe
I should
hmm okay that is not the most inspiring
move ever but it's pretty sound
he takes age three how one playing badly
oh oh
I shouldn't have blundered that one okay
I was a bit surprised that he took with
the e pawn that was a strange move but
it irritated me enough to happen about
that age three okay so what it's put
some pressure on the c6 porn
okay I can also take the B file if you
insist no problem Oh hmm bishop teacher
huh I'm not really seeing much here
that's not good
I thought you would take with the pawn
this is why I was spending time
five car to ask what is a good GM to
study that has a very narrow but good
opening repertoire jf or Volkov question
mark I'm not sure I don't understand mr.
Walker's openings or any any of its
place so hard for me to say
Dre EV is an excellent player to look at
of course especially if you play with
white yeah with one d4 he's one of the
it's got a great G for repertoire so do
I get that in that if I've moved somehow
f5 move I mean doesn't look like it what
a bad game what did i do there I was a
really bad game from that very nice
opening position pretty awful
okay I will still continue a little bit
very little hope though even with awful
technique you should win this and he
didn't play bad at all of this last
couple of moves
yeah we'll get this one right you will
get the upon that's the issue could have
played wrote you one as well but
hmm rupee three as a slight threat
there's some something that I can do
here was still made so stuff like that
probably not
now you can just check me Bishop c3 is
stalemate now not almost I have a Jeep
on yeah I have a Jeep on yeah okay I
have a Jeep on I guess so
let's resign this okay played that well
pretty bad all of this is opening I
should have won that actually out of the
opening it was too good
okay so playing the Blitz King here okay
I go I have five but they they all know
that nowadays with d4 and so on you
rarely get those good positions oh he
doesn't do it okay that's nice that
stick and hope for some funny attacking
game here III they all know it nowadays
how to defend against that stupid attack
not all of them but most players at FY
kind of attack we can try to slow him
down on the Queen side a little bit
interesting
yeah maybe takes 92 something like that
over to c4 it's a bit unsound
disposition I have not seen the game
hulking spurt nope
from the British ko Championships didn't
didn't look at any of those games okay I
simply I should think yeah I should I
should just think I absolutely didn't
think about what his idea was as a solid
we should be to nonsense
no it's not nonsense here takes my pawn
I should really think my playing a
little bit yeah I just play play moves
and I don't think that's not good just
it's just a terrible position
looking at see Foursquare trying to
train for Queen d7 f4 I mean there's
still some chances but it's a pretty
terrible game can I get that in Queen d7
yeah I mean if he goes nights before
even that is good for white just trading
into that end game yeah I can I can do
that maybe I can play maybe I can play
that
yeah yeah he goes for that yeah I don't
have a big choice there and I have to
take the pawn back that's a pretty
rubbish of d5 oh come on oh okay after
that game I really have to focus this is
just not acceptable I mean you can play
bad moves here and there but I'm just
playing like an idiot rook to you one
why that one that also wins yeah come on
yeah okay so let's focus now for a
couple of games that was really bad
really bad for counter-attack I don't
think so
her position was just terrible after a
Miss that the bishop comes to a three
before that I was okay I actually think
that this is no good you know that what
setup I mean you can play it but it
isn't particularly dangerous but the way
I played it it was super dangerous
okay nos dome I'm going to I'm going to
win that game now just have to apologize
that I'm a little bit less chatty I want
to play a decent game and beat this guy
yeah this is a line that I have some
experience with usually getting good
results with it black has to work a
little bit to get c5 and oh it's not
doing that so I'm going to take here and
now make sure that c5 has not played
that easily okay I can prevent him from
going c5 my position is better okay he
just plays it okay that's not good but I
understand that he feels a little bit
under pressure then I think I'll take
with this not quite clear how I should
take but I have to take the pawn
five interesting
okay I cannot take five I mean Lee okay
I can but mmm
d5 Bishop c5 queen chicks it looks wrong
okay I'm going back and check with the
knight on d4
okay taking the Queen Queen e2 looks
normal
yeah 25 I saw the move but I kicked I
didn't really see a good recipe against
it okay you can take a six now but then
he's got rook c5
okay this doesn't look great but I
couldn't really see an alternative hmm
there he goes eight five now and I don't
quite see what I'm doing then no he's
playing this the super aggressive style
after so I have to go back yeah it's
quite funny it's actually the many
Brazilian players have a very active and
somewhat unsound style it's really
really funny so almost some kind of
pattern even the strong ones so what is
this
just the chicken if true of course but I
can play rook c1 or something we should
be true then
I don't think I can take him let him
take that on f2
okay I don't see a great move there
you should see four screens III just
completely bonkers stuff
but everybody really hate those kind of
game you're like winning after move 15
or something and he kind of wriggles
himself out of it and can just take it
for and I have no idea what he's
thinking about you they are now a desert
Oh is there something that I don't see
here I don't see a chapter or anything
I have no live tournaments planned at
the moment
doesn't look like I win this game as I
had planned and yeah I don't know bit of
a shame
trying for counter play against f7 of
course but maybe you can still just play
the B phone up
want you to go to f6 it seems alright I
can take let's try
mm-hm Queen d5 is some kind of maid if I
can get that in I have rook a one in
some cases no we can just take this oh
come on
27 if I go Queen d7 where is he going
with this Queen d7 okay then I have to
win the next game what a bet what a bad
streak here what am I doing here that's
really bad right I lost three in a row
I won two then I lost three in a row
playing like a complete [ __ ] okay I
have to win that one so what it seemed
Smita wait said one of those guys no
yeah I didn't understand many moves that
my opponent played and with this and now
I get this line or come on
you're really of torturing me now with
this kind of with this kind of lines
that I always forget to look at okay
I'll play something something passive
here the default line is it's on my list
for ages to finally check yeah and oh
it's what guess that I always forget
that
some cool process the BR icy countries
will take over the world I don't even
know what these countries are can you
elaborate
I don't know what these countries are I
think you were talking about Brazil
earlier so the B is probably for Brazil
but Brazil taking over the world I
cannot really I don't really see why
that should happen May 25 you know that
I can do there
yeah he got that Bishop on his seven but
that wasn't the greatest piece our
that's a pretty annoying pin there once
again not a very nice position I don't
like to play g5 here but I think I have
to
oh my I really hate my performance yeah
that's not good
hey Paul is also weak
yeah I could have played a fire from
pretty sure he could have done that but
it's a it's terrible for black and in
many ways the way you plays it is
perfectly fine against MIT I have an 80%
score and lost one game out of seven but
this will be the second one today
everybody's outplay me it's not even
that that I'm playing badly but they
also play well let's was a bit
surprising
did he even calculate all this can you
believe that
I mean this actually helped my position
a little bit it was even worse before
okay now I can theoretically speaking
take the queen but that's that doesn't
that doesn't look good yeah at least I
get the D foul that's not so bad
me black is clearly worse and everything
but at least I'm sort of hanging in
there okay so it's not taking a pawn
that's good news so let's go in and now
I'm pretty okay with my position here
that that could have been much worse
okay so I'm okay yeah I can offer a draw
yeah maybe you will take it good no no
you get no problems whatsoever now I
think Wow okay just stay active here
can I draw a c4 I think I can so let's
do that
that must be a draw I was a bit maybe a
bit dicey but I think it says I think
this is a draw g4 h for the draw f4 f6
is a draw
yeah that's it wrong okay I offered the
draw I can't this is this is a complete
draw now come on so I somehow save this
scheme or I don't know hmm oh I screwed
up whatever you want to make oh and it
was a very lucky lucky escape
Wow pretty awful but as somehow somewhat
small saved it Hermann Steiner so come
on let's make a draw and so that's wind
will not make a draw against Hermann
Steiner why does he have to play the
most boring no he doesn't
he plays oops the Belgrade gambit okay
what kind of stuff is that this is an
opening funny
someone says Magnus Ventforet he's
trying to win
how can you try to win that position
that cards and head I saw that position
one hour ago
and it was just completely dead so I
really have no idea our garden our cars
and I should try to win wasn't Herman
Steiner that guy who also played with
the Hollywood people the Hollywood
celebrities like Humphrey Bogart and
people like that or am i confusing
things
it was really it would be it would be a
pure miracle if Carleton wins that game
against Adams it was just like
completely dead at least for my in
comparison certainly untrained I'm yeah
mr. styler is now taking a big timeout
and now goes for Bishop g5 okay as he
tried to castle long maybe yes
okay I cancel I like those older movies
yesterday I'm not
another huge expert have to admit why is
he never playing a move that I expect I
thought he would at least try to use
that that pin he it's just a complete
pawn down okay
well I watch the new Star Wars movie
what kind of question is that say
anybody in the world who was he was kind
of growing up in the 1980s who's not
watching that movie you have to be yeah
I mean nah I mean you have to be
absolutely like I don't know I don't
know what you have to be to not watch it
some summer yet I guess even though I
have no idea what to expect but I mean
Harrison Ford is like 70 I is playing
Han Solo isn't that great I will watch
that of course
so he tries to do stuff with this night
hmm
yeah my point structure it's not exactly
great
I wonder what to do here I wonder if
eight five is a movement looks like
amazing
yeah live under a rock or have no hard
or stuff like that maybe be female yeah
that's also something I have never
played Star Trek chess no okay I can do
B b6 or something
you cannot take I wonder if that is any
good yeah what I'm doing I think he
definitely yes has gained in the last
couple of moves it's really questionable
what if my position is any good so you
could be eight that doesn't look great
doesn't look great
yeah I'm getting this one but you can
take c5 if he likes I don't think it's
so great but we'll see
I definitely played this very badly yeah
I think Luke should be in the movie
right I mean I think there was some
suspense about about the trailer okay so
what is this I'm going to cover that
it's probably a draw anyway but Oh
rook d7 is going Roxy one nature
yeah it's very uncomfortable I wonder I
mean I probably have to give up stuff at
one point
going going around with the rook here oh
my
it's really awful after that opening I
mean he was basically it's just a bone
down how to move five and I managed to
play it in such a bad way
you
and he's playing that well yeah it's not
so bad I mean maybe I can win on time
I can't offer I read wrong probably
wants to try to win yeah that's
understandable now for him draw two
times if he doesn't take it I'm gonna
have to win on time
okay I won that on time I offered the
draw two times more that can I do I
don't just give up okay um so what do we
have some questions you know no I don't
resign Haman Steiner says how about
resigning when you're clearly crushed
yeah I don't see any point in that I
mean okay so if you just can just off
you can just take the draw if he's
playing so slowly what can I do I want
you do one thing
is there still a game Wow
it's a bit screwed up but Adams cousin
is still playing that and he's winning
right or isn't that a win it's cars
really getting a winner out of this game
that's cool I don't know I really don't
feel qualified today
yeah okay guys you have many
possibilities to watch this with
commentary and later so I'm going to I'm
going to stop the broadcast now after
not more than the usual 60 60 minutes I
so hope you like that even though I was
kind of in bad shape thanks for watching
and hope to see you next week